welcome to this video playing chromos
here from oops from Norway yeah he plays
this and never bothered bothered
bothered bothered to study the dis
opening and just play something against
the against the Chigi ring and yeah
quite often I feel like I'm I shouldn't
study something because it's not that
bad and quite often I I don't get good
positions okay maybe maybe this is not
one of those cases that looks quite nice
actually b6 giving his light squares
away so Bishop g5 maybe I can get this
traded and f6 I don't know if he wants
to do that maybe
okay so i get that should take putting
the rukon the cfl
yeah what is he doing f5f5f5 something
like that maybe it looks like it here
King edge 8 a-5 has a point that it
takes away the Knights the the square of
this night so no here we go yeah i was
thinking i go Bishop g5 he has 96 theses
this is awkward
yeah maybe just this up but simple but
not so bad
sit at the seep seep seep on to check
okay just goes back
I should i'd like to have c1 there for
the bishop in case you really place a
form
would be nice to play a for myself but
really get this going
yeah maybe maybe let's just try to play
a form and if he wants to prevent it he
really has to play this very committed
life for move which is not really clear
that he wants to do it gives me 93 for
all the time I always kept the knight on
c3 there Wow print right here that's
that's that's surprising
hmm ok let's get this in
fatigues I have this ideas to you say
six square within 9 to e six maybe ok so
back here I guess
i D 46s idea now we're d5 pawn of course
is weak so okay if I play that now 95 96
okay it's not such a great idea
hmm
sure it's not so bad for him interesting
very interesting preparing f3 Jack just
to get a little bit more space down
90 night night now and i don't know
let's just improve the whole thing a
little bit Knight c3 Bishop t4 and so on
keep that all protected you should be
four possibly Bishop b5 this is this way
forward without any kind of risk
yeah that it looks okay but how do i
force him to ever take them that's the
real issue before 94 i think is okay
I never expect any mafia bg5 Wow ever
said that that coming from check the
whole game is on the queenside and he
goes g5 not saying it's bad it's just
hey I never really looked at this in a
little bit even okay i still cannot
takes away for okay where my development
I mean I go on the development is wrong
I mean though like coordination just a
little bit slow here
yeah time intake is in this 9790 reason
Pretty Polly Ronnie fork I know wait can
check inside and take you five when I
distract can you believe that my night
is strapped unbelievable stuff that's
sick that's just sick how lucky can you
be really sure I can win this on time
grah Arthur ha IR cam droids ok DRA gone
dry for to choke for to choke there yeah
998 yeah it looks like I'm peas up and
I'm not yeah this is just crazy it's
just crazy
yeah well there it was a very difficult
position I think he I'm i'm okay i
probably have to be some more precise
there somehow this is an interesting
move I didn't really consider to take
maybe that was not not the right way to
go check Jim that is too slow it's just
too slow he can this is am I totally
underestimated that idea I should have
should have fun focus on other things
here like Rudy you won or something
getting play on the e-file maybe I
should have taken bed in the first place
here on c6 does this thing okay this is
you blundering stuff this is a bit
better for idea yeah probably probably
it's it's nothing nothing substantial
yeah something like that it looks a
little bit awkward for black but there's
no it's nothing serious m yeah I'm check
and g4 have to form interesting very
interesting as a very complicated type
of position the d5 pawn is a very very
debatable let's say object in this
position it is either it's at the same
time it's a strength but it's same time
it's a weakness so very difficult very
difficult to play ok well thanks for
watching